WINDOWS XP:
This wallpaper is by far the most recognizable
wallpaper in the world.
In fact, this wallpaper may be the most viewed
and potentially most nostalgic photo of all
time.
Whether you’re a casual computer user who
just uses computers to check emails or you’re
a PC enthusiast who loves to build your’re
own water cooled systems, this wallpaper unites
us all.
And it’s not something that we just recognize
either, it’s a blast to the past, a reminder
of the revolution that computers are.
But, there’s been several revolutionary
launches since then but none of those wallpapers
are anywhere near as recognizable or nostalgic.
For example, this was the wallpaper that Steve
Jobs used in the original iPhone keynote in
2007 but unless you’re an Apple fanboy,
you probably didn’t even know that.
And as for Android, has their ever even been
a wallpaper that was iconic of the OS?
I would say the answer is no, but what makes
XP even more interesting is that it wasn’t
even the first OS from Microsoft.
In fact, it didn’t come out till 16 years
after the original version of Windows.
Before Windows XP, there was Windows 1.0,
2.0, OS/2, 3.1, NT 3.X, 95, NT 4.0, 98, 2000,
and ME.
So, Windows XP was actually the 12th iteration
of Windows and there’s been plenty since
then as well.
This includes Windows Vista, 7, 8, 10, and
most recently 11.
But despite all these versions, Windows XP
remains OG.
Coincidentally, the iPhone is at the same
age right now as Windows was when XP came
out.
So, that wallpaper going viral is similar
to an iPhone 15 wallpaper going viral and
being remembered for decades.
Now, I don’t know about you but I don’t
think the iPhone 15 will be remembered in
a few decades much less its bubbly wallpapers.
With that being said, it didn’t seem like
XP would be a gamechanger at launch either.
In fact, the cards were very much stacked
against Microsoft from all fronts.
So, join me as we take a look back at what
made Windows XP beat the odds and basically
became the symbol of computers?
AN UPHILL BATTLE:
Given the success of XP, you would probably
be inclined to think that XP came out during
the peak of Microsoft.
During a time when everyone was excited about
Microsoft and Windows and computers.
This sort of situation is what usually leads
to such nostalgia.
For example, when Gmail, YouTube, and Chrome
came out, most people were rooting for Google.
Google was the internet company of the people,
but the same could not be said about Microsoft.
In fact, it was actually quite the opposite.
You see, Microsoft was actually caught up
in one of the most influential court cases
of all time: United States vs Microsoft.
Essentially, regulators were claiming that
Microsoft was a monopoly which they definitely
were.
Regulators were hoping to split the company
into 2: one that was in charge of producing
operating systems and one that was in charge
of producing all other pieces of software
like Office and Internet Explorer.
In fact, the only reason that this motion
didn’t go through is because of a technical
legal violation.
The judge that was overseeing the case had
talked with the press while the case was ongoing
which was a violation of conduct, nullifying
the subsequent ruling.
So, instead of being broken up, Microsoft
would end up settling with the DOJ on November
2, 2001.
But, while Microsoft had narrowly avoided
a breakup, this only made public sentiment
around Microsoft even worse.
And this was the context in which Windows
XP was launched.
In fact, XP was launched on October 25, 2001,
so just one week before the settlement during
which consumer sentiment against Microsoft
was worse than ever.
Too make things worse, Microsoft was becoming
a lot stricter with their anti piracy policy.
XP was the first version that required Windows
Product Activation which just rubbed people
the wrong way as it just made Microsoft look
greedy and that was just the tip of the iceberg.
You know how Apple gets a bunch of slack for
not allowing users to customize their products.
With the Mac Studio for example, if you swap
out the SSD, the computer will no longer boot.
If you ask Apple, they’ll say that this
is “a security feature” that ensures that
the data on your SSD is safe, but in reality,
it’s just a way to force people to come
to Apple if they need storage upgrades.
Coming from Apple though, this is really not
surprising but did you know that Microsoft
was doing the exact same thing over 20 years
ago?
That’s right, XP is dependent on the specific
motherboard chipset that it’s originally
installed with to boot.
So, if you swap hard drives, the computer
will no longer boot.
The only logical reason for this was to force
consumers to buy a new Windows license with
each computer.
So, basically, people were dealing with a
Google style monopoly with the anti consumer
practices of Apple.
This was the context in which XP was launched.
But, it wasn’t just the context that wasn’t
optimal, XP itself came with a lot of shortcomings
starting with bloatware.
This was actually the main reason for the
anti trust lawsuit in the first place.
Microsoft was leveraging their OS monopoly
to push crappy software like Internet Explorer
and MSN Messenger.
This effectively killed the competition within
the browser space from players like Netscape.
But not only was XP filled with bloatware,
it was also filled major security risks.
Remember how computer viruses were a serious
concern back in the early 2000s?
Well, a lot of that is thanks to the security
of XP or I guess lack thereof.
We can really get into the weeds of this one
but essentially, Microsoft went ahead and
connected XP computers directly to the internet
with their TCP/IP protocol instead of having
some sort of security layer in between.
This was despite several expert warnings months
before XP even came out.
And what was the result of all of this?
Well, XP became a virus magnet.
So, to sum things up, XP came out from a widely
hated monopoly and was filled with bloatware
and fundamental security issues.
You would think that such a combination would
lead to a disgraced OS like Windows 8 but
somehow XP would go onto be the most nostalgic
OS of all time, so what in the world happened?
THE XP ADVANTAGE:
I know we’ve been largely trashing on XP
and Microsoft so far but there’s a lot of
great things to say about XP as well starting
with it’s UI.
Not only was XP easy to use but it was the
first OS that seemed appealing to use.
I mean, until XP, this is how Windows looked.
The task bar was gray, the windows were gray,
the entire OS was gray.
This is because the main focus until XP was
functionality, not aesthetics.
People bought computers to draft documents,
research, learn coding, and send emails, not
to mess around with.
Moreover, Microsoft had their plates full
with building out functionality itself.
But, by the time we got to XP though, Microsoft
was able to focus on the UI side of things
as well, making computers inviting to use.
Now of course, XP is nothing in comparison
to 2023 standards but for 2001 standards,
this was revolutionary.
Computers had also made massive strides in
terms of stability.
Yes, they were still very much prone to viruses
but the OS itself was more stable than ever.
I could go on and point out a bunch of other
advantages of XP but honestly, , I don’t
think the success of XP has anything to do
with XP itself.
Sure, it was decently stable OS with a friendly
UI and nice colors but the real reason that
XP was so successful was because of a larger
trend.
Take a look at this graph of annual PC shipments
for example.
You can almost see the different market segments.
Between 1981 and 1992, you have the geek era.
During this period, it was only hardcore nerds
and geeks that used computers.
The type of people who learn coding for fun
and like building PCs in their spare time.
Between 1992 and 2002, you have the early
adopter era.
These people weren’t necessarily super into
computers per se but they could see that computers
were the next big thing.
They saw that you could use computers to communicate,
research, and learn more than ever before
and they wanted to be ahead of the curve.
And then you have the 2002 to 2010 era.
This was when the general public finally bought
into the idea of computers and more importantly
the internet.
They saw that you could ask Google any question
you wanted and learn about any topic.
They saw that you could talk to your family
across the world through Hotmail, Gmail, and
eventually Skype.
They saw that you could keep in touch with
your friends like never before with Friendster,
MySpace, and Facebook.
Most importantly though, they too saw that
computers were an essential part of the future.
And it was really all of these internet based
services that sold that vision to the general
public.
It wasn’t just people that were coming to
this realization either.
It was also schools, companies, governments.
All of sudden, elementary schools started
sporting computer labs, old school companies
started buliding IT departments, and governments
organizations started assembling crappy yet
functional websites.
All of this led to computer sales rocketing
from a 150 million per year to 350 million
per year.
And what did all of these computers have in
common?
You guessed it, they shipped with XP but this
insane wave of computer adoption only tells
half the story.
You see, XP wouldn’t be nearly as iconic
if it wasn’t for the subsequent fall.
THE BIGGER PICTURE:
Panning over to the post 2010 era, you’ll
see that PC shipments started falling like
a rock.
We would see a surge during the pandemic but
that’s already starting to wear off.
The reason for this isn’t rocket science.
It’s because smartphones started taking
off which largely reduced the need for computers.
And this had a very interesting impact on
the role of computers.
People didn’t just get rid of their computers
or anything but computers largely became relegated
into being a productivity tool.
Most people use computers to solely do job
related work or school related work.
This includes writing emails, attending zoom
meetings, working on excel sheets, making
presentations, writing code, and so on.
All forms of entertainment have moved over
to smartphones.
This includes texting, social media, video
calls, shopping, listening to music, playing
mobile games, and even watching YouTube.
In fact, almost 2/3s of all YouTube watch
time comes from mobile devices.
Likely the only exception to this trend is
PC gaming.
For everyone else though, computers have mainly
become a productivity tool for the most part.
This is in stark contrast to the early 2000s
when computers had nothing to do with most
people’s jobs.
As such, people tended to view computers as
a personal device for emailing your friends,
and social media as opposed to a work device.
So, it was only natural that people had a
greater emotional connection to the defining
aspects of early 2000s computers which happened
to be Windows XP and this wallpaper.
As computers become work devices though, a
lot of that connection wore off and that’s
why people don’t have the same nostalgia
towards Windows 7 or Windows 10.
As for the people who’s jobs never became
computerized, well, many of these people either
never upgraded or waited a super long time
before upgrading.
In fact, when Microsoft discontinued XP in
2014, 3 in 10 computer users were still using
XP, which translated to a quarter billion
people.
In fact, nearly 20 years after it’s launch,
millions of people still use XP.
So for a lot of computer users, XP was simply
the OS that they used for the longest time
making it a classic.
At the end of the day, XP was by no means
the perfect OS nor was it launched under the
perfect circumstances; in fact, the circumstances
for Microsoft were far from perfect.
The circumstances for the PC industry as a
whole however were better than ever.
And for a substantial portion of the population,
the glory days of using computers for entertainment
ended up being the XP days and XP is often
the OS they used for the longest time.
And that’s why this wallpaper is so nostalgic.
I guess it’s a good thing that Microsoft
didn’t cheap out and spent over a $100 grand
getting this photo.
While Microsoft’s foray into the PC world
played out extremely well, the same cannot
be said about their smartphone ambitions.
Check out this video to learn more.